actually when I did The Departed uh I  was I was in this rehearsal uh in in  pre-production and it was just me and  Jack Nicholson and Scorsese uh we had a  few hours together and at one point  Marty got up to either use the bathroom  or have a cup of coffee or something and  and it was just me and Jack in the room  and he turned around and he goes out of  nowhere he goes you know I never would  have made it this far in my career if I  wasn't a great [ __ ] writer really  yeah out of out of nowhere and it was  the most and I went like and it was like  everything clicked into place and I went  of course like how do you have a 40-year  career right without being able to put  your own kind of imprimatur on something  or you know I understand fix it yeah fix  it or not or not touch a comma of it  right you know what I mean and he knew  it and be more often right than wrong  it's like it's because he was a great  writer and and I watched him  do incredible things